yeah hello welcome to this video
yeah this is a video about my book
release yeah as simple as that
this will be yeah pretty blatant
advertisement for my book I have to be
frank about that this is about promoting
my book okay it's out you can buy it
I've got one copy here and in fact I've
got a couple of more copies yeah those
red books on my shelf
those are copies of the book I got some
from the from the publisher yeah it's
out and I want to present it to you um
of course um yeah many many of you may
have gathered some information due to
various videos in the past but still I'd
feel yeah some video is in order to show
the contents of the book and maybe give
you an idea if it is something for you
or not
so it's an opening book and it's about
the nihms oh and bogu Indian this is the
title of the book name is rainbow Indian
yeah what what is that yeah just to
start it's a black opening repertoire
book and it handles everything that
happens after d4 Knight f6 c4 in a
particular fashion black goes eat six
and he's intense to play with Bishop to
b4 getting that Bishop out and in one
case it's the nimzo-indian with this
painting idea or in the other case if
they go huh Knight to f3 or g3 those are
the two main alternatives black also has
this check and this is the BOGO Indian
this is where the title is coming from
it's an opening repertoire book for
black which basically deals with
everything that happens here so d4 see
form it does not have stuff like let's
say um here to empower ski jump off ski
another queen pawn openings or Bishop f4
93 yeah those kind of rare lines that
are not in there it deals with the most
critical move c4 and then my suggestion
in that book is to go is six Bishop
before the book was intended to be like
260 pages but it got to 440 at the end
so it's a pretty pretty thick looking
book it's not as bad as it sounds as
some the print is some relatively large
so it's easy to read and I think it's
very it's it's it's it's reader friendly
let's say young term and also like the
production value of the book would
really I do it's not just because it's
mine I think it looks and feels nice in
your hand it's makes a good good
impression it doesn't feel very cheap or
anything it's not a how do you call it
um it's not very it's not a German you
say good woundn't bounce no it's not
it's a flexible cover but it's pretty
pretty nice I think yeah so um what is
the repertoire book
it's designed to suggest an opening
repertoire for black after that so I'm
not dealing with every possible
continuation that both sides may play
I'm suggesting a play for black however
on everything that white may throw at
you so it's a it's a whole bunch of
suggestions what to do on particular
white ideas in some cases I only suggest
one particular reply in some cases I
suggest I give you a selection of two or
more in some cases I will also yeah
sprinkle in let's say little suggestions
like okay this is my main move but if
you maybe have some time on your hands
or you are interested in expanding
repertoire you may also do this in that
so I'm hinting at other ideas at times
you have to limit yourself to something
and you cannot just present everything
nowadays
and yeah otherwise you would get if you
would make a book on the news oh and bow
go and show everything possible it would
be a 2,000 page book it's really not
very practical so let me tell you what
is in the book yeah what what kind of
lines do I present the whole idea was to
try to present lines that follow a
somewhat common theme or common kind of
structure and the structure that black
is usually aiming for in my book is
something like that I'm going to show
you one particular line that is a
cornerstone of that repertoire this line
here this is called the Huebner
variation called
or named after the German Grand Master
Robert Huebner the Huebner variation is
a very typical variation for the one
that I'm trying to reach in the book
black will often give up his dark
squared bishop capturing on c3 sometimes
creating a double poem sometimes not and
after the capture giving up the bishop
he will put his pawn some unmarked in
that put his pawns on dark squares
mostly on dark squares which means that
the dark square bishop is gone you put
them on dark square so you have a good
Bishop 1ca this is a good piece in
relation to the pawn structure black
will have a very healthy long term
healthy structure this is what somewhat
links the lines together whenever
possible I was trying to do something
comparable it's not easy to do in some
cases it is impossible and I had to go
for something else but in general the
common link between the lines is a dark
squared strategy pawns going on dark
squares with the bishop exchanged on c3
as mentioned sometimes possible
sometimes not but there are some common
themes definitely
that link the variations together um
let's have an overview what am i what am
i choosing if we start with the
nimzo-indian there are a couple of lines
of course the Newtonian is one of the
most popular opening some in chess and
also some time ago made a chess openings
uncovered video represented the whole
nimzo-indian complex I'm just going to
show you what I do recommend in the book
vs various things that one may throw at
you I start with the absolute sidelines
um those are something like a queen bee
three Queen B 3 is some relatively
harmless move after which I suggest to
go c5 this is the prescribed antidote
for a very long time you attack that
pawn quite directly using it or using
the fact that the queen is not
protecting that pawn anymore here theory
hasn't changed in the last let's say 10
20 30 years it's considered harmless and
probably nothing will change with that
alternatively I also mentioned that move
which allows this more typical d65 this
dark squad center c5 otherwise just good
Bishop d2 that's a rare nice bit
Passavant
after which my suggestion in the book is
to play the move Knight to c6 after
Knight f3 to go d6 and simply play in
the similar fashion as we would against
the classical variation with an early
Queen c2 we go d6 we go we 5 and we put
the pawns on the dark squares as we
mentioned the common strategy or the
common link of pawn structure in that
book it's that's an easy thing to learn
and Bishop t2 is a move that even though
I have played the names over numerous
times I never got it's very rare another
move that falls under the somewhat rare
category is the move Bishop to g5
this is the Leningrad variation this
move forever is a little bit more
serious than the other ones and it is
played more often against that I do
recommend something that is not so
common my recommendation is to go again
with c5 almost all the time I'm playing
a c5 based approach because it fits well
with that dark-squared strategy putting
that on a dark square d5 is what reply
and now black has quite a number of
options one option that would actually
fit well into my strategy and do
something that I also mentioned is
something like that checking and now go
d6 + e5 the reason why I did not choose
that is that it has been basically
covered to death in other books it's
it's in every other repertoire book on
the nihms oh and no not that there are
so many but there are two or three and
they all have that line yeah and I felt
well not not the same thing again yeah
just let's look at something else and I
found another line which is very good in
fact and this is a line okay it's
without h6 it's not a big deal where
black takes and goes g6 that's quite
interesting black is basically playing a
kind of benoni which is also dark square
but with the bishop on before yeah
that's quite interesting for example um
what is my doing but mostly they go
something like this
III like castles this 97 and black will
often go Knight to e5 possibly not g6
and in ideas a 6 B 5 c4 in benoni style
black has an excellent score at that
with that line I was very surprised to
see how good that actually is it's a
very good alternative line that leads to
interesting play so that fit my Billa
perfectly it is the first currency of
the so-called namizo benoni it's a Ben
Oni tab structure C 556 with the bishop
here and this looks weird and the bishop
is often or in the bandoneon is on on
g7 normally but here this has some
points sometimes black gets to play C
for b5 and the bishop back for example
we see that structure and other in other
lines as well
yeah the Leningrad not a very common
line but it can be answered with that
would that suggestion pretty pretty well
I think
what else does white have one dangerous
line really is the same issue variation
that's old-fashioned but interesting
like shakes and I suggest to play with
an early c5 again um the same which is
something that I've played a bit myself
with white in in blitz chess the reason
is I have to be totally Frank there I
always thought that this that Samish
isn't a good line I always thought it is
bad basically putting too much of yeah
structural weaknesses in in White's camp
but when I looked at this for the book I
really recognized that it has some
danger black has to be a bit careful
it's not something that is easily played
with black so I was really am yeah I was
looking in detail of who'd like to find
something good and the best thing
actually for black is to play this is
total mainline 32 will be 6e 498 this is
the total mainline of that opening and
it's also totally ok for black if he
knows what is doing the move 98 by the
way it's very key it's very important to
not play some lame move and allow that's
very very awkward pin okay I don't want
to now show you the whole the whole
repertoire in total detail just in over
you against this image I recommend the
main line one reason is why I want I go
for the main line is that sometimes also
white starts with the move III and after
castles c5 sorry Bishop b3 c5 this is a
line that I recommend against III
against the Rubinstein um that here
right still has
this option of a three and sharePlex
choice is severely limited in comparison
to the moves a three the damage on move
four but the main line as I mentioned
this thing is still possible so it's
just yeah it's one line that is working
regardless of whites move order this is
important yeah the same is dangerous but
if you know what you're doing not a
problem
so what else is there there is f3 this
line is important it's gaining in
popularity and has been the choice in
many top-level games what is my
recommendation yeah my recommendation is
to yeah basically fight fire with fire
and this is a an aggressive line and you
should counter aggressively my
suggestion is to play c5 d5 castles and
now after you form I give two lines
actually if this is the case where I
give two lines um my main line my main
recommendation is to move b5 which is a
very sharp approach that can really net
you yeah quick victories if white is
making any mistake it's a very sharp
continuation on the other hand it's also
something that requires to learn some
specific theoretical lines some this is
something where you have to put in a
little bit of work it's it's it's work
to play that white for example can play
this kind of thing gaining lots of space
and black is counter attacking in the
center a very sharp stuff but very
interesting so it's worth looking at but
it's it's sharp for those who don't feel
so much like learning that there's also
the move d6 which I recommend as an
alternative line this is the line that
you can play without so much concrete
knowledge for example this was played by
Magnus Carlsen in a game last year
against nakum
Kozma also didn't go for that super
sharp line quite typically but it was
for that this is interesting
it still can lead to gambit play like
this for example this is a stronger
version even of that that we saw before
um or let's say 92 again b5 is good it's
a bit of a delay of that b5 move in some
cases however like after 9f for black is
some black is not really giving up a
pawn that gets an interesting being only
type of position after a six recently
topple off
played this against Grisha octopi love
is also an expert of that line let then
I don't feature but I go a 6 as to power
of the de in another game which also
gives black very interesting player it's
a really aggressive variation but it's a
little bit less critical on concrete
concrete moves than the other b5 line
so again step three you have to play a
somewhat sharp variation now if you play
something meek I don't like the position
from black um that's f3 Knight f3
another option this is a totally
different approach to f3 here white is
more putting his some hope of getting
some on piece play um again I recommend
to play with c5 yeah attacking the
center from a dark square um
right normally continues with g3 that's
one point of that field shadowing and
now my recommendation is to go like this
attacking that night I have a huge
experience with that line in Blitzer if
you watch my channel regularly you
probably will find a couple of games
with that and usually my results are
pretty ok white now has two moves you
can play Queen d3 after which normally
this is reached here blacks position is
very comfortable or if they know it a
little bit better they play Bishop t2
after that I'm taking
and take here and then here well Black
has a couple of moves Queen b6 castles
that's not very move on a dependent but
the general thing that what happens is
that black after castles and d6 builds
up Hedgehog type of position that is a
bit non-typical but for the book and
also for the limb zone but it is a
hedgehog position where black has the
bishop pair that's pretty nice because
if you think about it something like
this for example let's just put some
moves on okay why probably knock a b2
wasn't hanging but I just want to show
the point if white wants to get
somewhere against this head Shakhtar go
set up he often has to push pawns
forward before ever and so on and
ultimately something will open up and
then the bishop pair is important
especially the dark squared bishop I
like that idea and this is also a line
that's course pretty decently for black
so this is my recommendation against
against this line alternatively I also
analyze this a little bit for people who
want to give the double pawn yeah not
not a bad alternative so these are the
sight lines let's say the nihms oh how
ever we decide line some if you if you
want to want a statistical overview
let's say over the names o of the time
people play queens on to the other 30%
they playing u3 and the rest is the
other 40% so the sidelines comprise
about 35 to 40% and in 30% of the time
you will get Queen c2 and the other 30%
you get a three let's start with Quincy
to the classical variation here I'm
recommending 96 the zurich variation
after the Swiss city sewer 96 innertext
upon and the main benefit of that line
is that you get this D 6 e 5 cent
almost all of the time this almost this
is reef now I think there is no line
where white is avoiding that in some way
so you get the desired structure c5 in
this particular case which is what we
play in in other cases here after takes
is an entirely entirely different line
this would lead to something that looks
more like a Sicilian or sometimes like
an English head shock you know ninety
six an interesting move 93 and then we
go would be six and my idea is always to
play e5 the White has two options here
he can try to recapture with the bishop
on c3 or you can recapture with the
Queen in some cases this is one
continuation in some cases I suggest
aggressive lines for black for example
here after castles before black has a
very interesting pawn sacrifice with e5
this is very interesting and something
like that gives black excellent
compensation for the pawn this is one
line that are analyzed quite deeply
however if you don't want to sacrifice a
pawn you can also go a five in that
particular position and prevent before
and later you will play queenie 75 the
good thing about the zurich variation is
it can be played almost without knowing
so many concrete lines i give lots of
concrete lines and i give lots of sample
games and sample variations to
illustrate how this line is played it's
something where you have to develop some
kind of field for the position then you
will be able to play it really without
recalling specific lines this is a
common theme also in the book i wanted
to present something which gives you the
chance to still play that position in
case you have forgotten what you learned
in some cases it's
for example after against this f3 line
that I showed earlier I am I want to
want to remind you aware I recommend
this b5 approaches here it's it's really
essential to learn a little bit of stuff
but in return you get a very active very
interesting position against Queen c2
the Zurich is something that I think
many players play without really knowing
that much yeah they're just saying okay
I want the points here d6 + e5 and then
I'm then I'm good okay I deliver a
little bit more but in general it is
like that you can play that without
particular mmm yeah memory requirements
however I have to say that in some lines
like this for example white place III it
is not clear if black equalizes
completely there are two or three lines
maybe to wear white maintains a slight
advantage for example after you file d5
not be 892 I think why it has a little
bit of an advantage this also was
featured in blitz games of mine where I
where I refer to that as one of the best
lines however it's not played that often
there's just one player on line who
continues to play that against me but
many others even grandmasters play
different lines it's not the end of the
world but it's something that I deal
with in an honest way I really don't
feel like claiming everything is rosy
when widened effect maybe has a slight
advantage and in this case he can get
one with very precise play however we
don't make it easy for what if you know
your stuff here it won't be won't be an
easy task
yeah that's the zurich variation in
short the other main continuation is III
the Rubinstein variation after which I
recommend a c5 based approach however
I'd like to start with castles and not
with c5 there's one reason for them
after c5 92 wide manages to move a three
and black will probably have to take on
c3 and white will recapture a couple of
lines - what that but this didn't feel
didn't feel right for me in my
repertoire context I prefer to Castle
one point is that after Knight to e2
if white intends to go a3 and after the
capture to recapture with the night so
let's say I do something stupid Jack you
know this kind of thing this is just not
good yeah Black has given up his Bishop
and white doesn't have any particular
problem yeah let's say in return he
managed to yeah to recapture on c3 was a
snide and he will Castle shortly so I
think that black should play in a way
that lets this Knight stay only to that
it obstructs the further development so
my move is rookie age in my book the
ideas after a three to drop the bishop
back to evade the very neat maneuver and
it asks white how are you going to
develop your king side now the
consequence is that white in many cases
has to spend more time he has to play g3
for example after which d5 will put a
good foothold in the center if you want
a dark square strategy you can also go
d65 here it's also not bad but here d5
is just better yeah this is sorry g3 d5
this is a case where we have playing
pawns on light squares you cannot do it
all all the time let's say here's the
case where this kind of setup is better
if you really insist you can go d65 but
it's a bit different there
if white goes d5 black can play
something like d6 let's say 93 and c6
very interesting attacking that center
in some cases you can get a benoni
structure after takes takes and c5 even
but in some case you just take a couple
of times on d5
develop quickly very interesting I like
those lines and they can be played
without so much knowledge of concrete
lines if you play through the key games
in my book and this is something that I
should mention the book is based around
games
it features games that illustrate the
ideas um I think about 50 I don't
remember exactly how many is it let me
check
that's 44 the number changed a little
bit in the process it's centered around
games so I'll have complete games for
the lines that also show how the middle
game went and give you ideas how the
whole damn how the whole game proceeded
um yeah this was 92 the other main
option is Bishop b3 here then we go c5
and now after Knight e 2 we come to a
position where unfortunately again a
dark squad set up with d6 it's just not
cutting it yeah white we'll get some
fish appear under very favorable
circumstances here without any problem
and don't not losing time not doubling
the pawns so I'm recommending d5 here
that we'll need to iqp positions like
after let's say castles something like
that can happen yeah black has no
problem there whatsoever but it's it's a
bit different than then the other than
the other variation it's just a case
where other things are not good but no
big deal really like some setup is
somewhat similar almost regardless of
what white is doing so not much to worry
9 f3 is the main continuation then we do
knight c6 castles takes takes d6 and we
get to the Huebner after a 495 or after
9205 this is really the yeah the the
essence of this of our dark square
strategy loop them
and I'm very satisfied with what I got
there at the end it's a very complex
line strategically but also very
rewarding to study if you know that line
well and I'm not talking about concrete
moves talking about the ideas motifs and
so on and I'm really concentrating on
the different things they're in the
description um I think you have
excellent chances them it's not like
excellent chance that it's not like
black it's better but it is super
complex that positioned from a strategic
point of view and you will very often
find that white players have
difficulties with that position simply
because it's so strategically complex so
um very that's a very nice chapter
thinking my book it's one that I really
am very satisfied with especially
because at the beginning I had trouble
to understand some things and then
opening and I think I got somewhere at
the end so I'm pretty satisfied there
yeah that was the news oh yeah the
Huebner against e3 so what about this
yeah this leads to the BOGO Union Jack
check the good thing about this is
they're only three replies that need to
be checked in a book Knight c3 is a
transposition to the names oh we already
had that by the way in the nimzo-indian
before someone writes that in the
comments there's also this move but
after c5 we were transposed to Knight f3
on move four and then g3 this is just a
transposition I did not forget that in
the book just under different move water
so neither three check the original bogo
moves our Bishop d2 and 92 let's start
with this move Bishop detune the
recommendation the book is a five the
ideas of care okay we have to protect
that Bishop yeah so let's protect it and
the general idea is that black one
set up like that he will play the 65
according to the general strategic
outline and will try to play with
dark-squared pawns with the bishop
outside of the shape of the chain
sometimes it will trade sometimes not in
this particular case quite often the
bishop will not be traded actually
rather before bishop
one thing is for example if white care
was let us say Bishop g5 the this theme
is also on in other lines but black ball
taken and quite often to reroute this
Bishop to c5 in some cases this can
really lead to interesting taking games
it sounds kind of weird yeah black
attacking how is this going to work
yeah we're the cutoff Knight it comes to
e5 Bishop to c5 and then there are a
couple of pieces really get towards the
Kings side even h5h for sometimes an
idea well after canceling 11 an
interesting line I really like that
choice it's a bit much now to show all
the sub variations but in general I
think black is in pretty decent shape
and you can't play that without knowing
that many concrete lines I'm showing
them of course going through let's say
Knight c3 here or Queens to the capture
you have the couple of things possible
but that is my my main choice there it's
so pretty much this is the setup all of
the time the only slight exception is if
white goes 493 after that I don't think
that d6 is entirely equal but there's an
alternative line b6 which is also quite
nice one point is and this is a funny
part just so that the funny point is a
for intending a3 yeah exactly
this is an idea featured in the book
that's very cute look son the operating
on the fifth rank quite nice yeah so on
this is an interesting complex of lines
this is Bishop t2 white also has not be
determined this move
is a bit trickier to face in a
repertoire book um black hats tried a
number of lines and it seems to be that
the most interesting continuation is
castles and however this is very sharp
castles a3 Bishop e7 e 4 and now d5 yeah
black is counter striking in the center
he's better developed already castled
but there are some concrete problems
let's have a look Bishop d3 c5 all very
normal and now why tests that moves age
for this was virtually unknown until
like 2011 but nowadays this is the total
range in the in the night BD to BOGO
white just threatens very simply Bishop
age 7 wins and black has to react to
that threat you cannot simply not play
something like a no knight c6 yeah then
this is just wins it's the Greek gift so
black has to be circumspect they only
move really play a move is g6 which
looks kind of weird I know but that is
the only playable move and now after age
5 let's say we take and it gets very
very sharp quite obviously I feature
that line for black it is I think ok and
the current theoretical state is quite
okay for black really but it is very
very sharp I analyzed that thoroughly
and this is something that I really can
truly recommend especially because the
sight lines if white is doing something
else not this kind of yeah caveman style
approach in error in all other cases
black is absolutely fine
for example they for years they tried
stuff like before after which a 5v5 c5
and black already seems to be in good
shape on this also that was a bit it was
wrong that button
I know of course not sorry a three back
or that rides like this they try just
castling for example here black also is
in good shape in many cases is even
slightly better so um it's really a case
of make aged for work or not I didn't I
don't think it is that terrible for
black I think it's a pretty unclear line
where black seems to be okay
but you have to be ready for it it is
sharp so I thought that it would be
sensible for my book not to rely
entirely on that line and also
presenting something something that is
less yeah memory intense and I came up
with the line D six which is kind of
unknown no it's it's a bit of a rare
line but it's not bad I studied this and
planted myself successful migrants
against the grand master only or two
years ago the ideas again from black to
set up a dark squared center if white
plays very slow very slow ish like that
said g3 we can easily do this and go e5
no problem at all the other line and
this is a bit more dangerous I think
it's white going a3 after which we have
to take chat and why does recapturing
can also take with the bishop both as
possible after that black should go or
should switch his set up a little bit
here for example it does make sense you
can go if five so terrible but I
recommend a different approach I
recommend you go with b6 Bishop here
Bishop e7 and blacks position is very
very very healthy but you can put a
piece on e4 most likely the bishop and
you have no particular problem you can
choose various ways to attack the center
this is the precise position that I got
at once against a grandmaster melle a
hotkey over two years ago and and
good position the whole game really it
was very satisfying
I think if white is very precise he can
keep a small advantage here but it's not
something very troublesome
I didn't mind to allow that the thing
was back then when I was playing in that
tournament I had the choice I could go
that I could play that super sharp line
or play d6 and I noticed that malahat Co
is a huge expert and I didn't have much
time to refresh my memory with the sharp
stuff so I decided to play d6 and just
play a game let's say this is the just
play a game so I was I'm glad that I
have those two alternatives there if
people are too scared let's say are
intimidated by this mu fear with those
sharp complications I give that
alternative with g6 um a third thing
that is in the book it's very it's a
very short chapter but Y can also do
this of course for a catalan for trying
to get to a kettle on d5 Bishop g2 would
be the Catalan opening chat so the check
this is one positive aspect of the big
win Ian in case of g3 we still play
Bishop before check it's basically the
same thing there is just there are just
very very small differences there to the
NIDA 3 move water why does committed to
g3 but not to Knight f3 sometimes you
can try to put a knight only 2 but it is
not very dangerous we can still do this
this and the overwhelming main line now
is still 93 transposing to the mainland
Bogle I feature the sidelines but I
think none of them are particularly
dangerous it's good to have seen once so
this is why I feature it but it's not a
big deal
92 is also possible after which you have
this move to transpose to what I showed
earlier well if you don't want that
I also feature the move c5 which seems
to be okay
as well this is how I played last year
against the German feeder master also I
got a very nice position there and won a
good game yeah this is the repertoire
overview for my book it took a while but
it's a it's a it's a big big area of
lines I'm looking at them the contents
know I didn't forget anything would have
been a bit embarrassing if I don't do my
own book but I can definitely say is
that I don't remember all the lines that
I have written in the book and you must
be honest there I simply don't but the
thing is if you choose the right lines
it does not matter so much you have
excellent chances to find the moves over
the board if you have a good
understanding of the common themes and
the ideas and I try to be idea heavy
yeah trying to explain where the pieces
should go and so on so I think it's
helpful to choose lines like that yeah
the book is in stores yeah you can order
it online if you are in the u.s. I think
you have to wait a couple of days to get
it from Amazon for example I think it is
scheduled for in about a week I'm not
quite sure about a week I think um from
from here the other way to get the book
and this is something that I mentioned
in an earlier video the other way to get
to get the book is directly from me um
the thing is that I have it's part of my
contract of an author that I can get
copies of the book at a slightly reduced
price so I can buy books from the
publisher and sell them directly um
which means that per book I earn a
little bit of something it's not much
it's not not like I can buy a Ferrari
next week but it earns me a couple of
bucks per book so if you want you can
also order it from me and quick we're
sending out and the costs will be about
the same as when you order it from a
shop it depends a little bit from where
you order it
what I do charges for the book I charge
the the German retail price which is 25
euros and I also charge something for
sending the book out which which is 3
euros for German people in for German
addresses and it's 8 euros for outside
Germany so if you end the US it would
cost you 33 years in total which makes
it about if you want US dollars like 37
or so and you would need to really put
it in a converter means that probably
from Amazon in like two weeks you'll get
it cheaper but if you get it from me it
would be a couple of extra dollars but I
earn a little bit of something and I
also of course when you order from me I
will also write some line yeah like yeah
this book is for person X enjoy it much
success with playing the opening or any
other specific line you want me to write
so if you're interested in in a copy
directly from me it would be nice and
I'm quick with sending out if you're
basically if you pay by a PayPal that's
the easy way to do it then I will
basically send out the same day or the
day after that if the post office is
closed a really quick with sending out
um I don't want to give out all the
information they are like my own yeah
like everything if you are interested in
ordering such a coffee please drop a
mail at my main address Christoph is a
lucky for the first name last name at
gmail.com I will also put it in the
video and yeah
contact me a mail and we will be quick
in arranging things yeah and term you
can also by the way read an extract of
my book on the homepage of the publisher
Bremen chess oh that will also be
visible in the video ok well guys thanks
for watching and yeah enjoy the book if
you have it already or if you want to
order it from some source or from me
directly it would be best
I enjoy it I think it's it's it's good
I'm satisfied I think it's it's a good
book thanks for watching guys bye